mme
[Applaudissements]
marois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et dix huit matches et stern
aussi
nothing and sexy
c'est oui charlotte vous vous appeler à
voter pour emmanuel macron sans illusion
l'une et l'autre pourquoi vos cet
engagement ce important là c'est trop
grave je trouve ça trop grave moi j'ai
on l'a déjà vécu mais mais j'ai trop
peur j'ai trop peur qu'elle passe
marine le pen elle a repris la route
dans la somme une mise en scène dans un
camion sur cinq petits mètres pour
montrer son soutien aux chauffeurs
routiers touché notamment par la hausse
des prix des carburants si demain marine
le pen était élue président de la
république qui applaudira dans le monde
ball sonar au trump or ban dida et
poutine
et ses cinq fantastiques l'unss et non
mais voilà je pense qu'il faut le faut
le dire en jeu
dans cette mise en scène orchestrée par
le kremlin le ministre de la défense
russe annonce à vladimir poutine une
victoire militaire la prise de mario
paul
les forces armées de la fédération de
russie et la milice de la république
populaire de données est ce qu ont
libéré marioupol le reste des formations
nationalistes se sont réfugiés dans la
zone industrielle de l'usiné à obstacles
c'est sans doute l'image qui raconte le
mieux la répression contre le milieu
artistique
des policiers
qui interrompent un concert dédié à la
paix entre la russie et l'ukraine
il faut évacuer
quelques notes de schubert jugeait trop
insolente par le pouvoir
[Musique]
le pianiste s'arrête la salle se lève
pour l'applaudir si vous avez besoin
d'un chanteur le talent c'est quoi ce
bail eh bien regardez cette image vous
serez pas déçus
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle veut pas de toi sinon elle n'aurait
pas fait ça n'essaye pas de chanter
parce que tu es plateau égalera bien je
vais terminer encore une fois en espèces
de palmiers pour moi c'est le caniveau
de tout de la pensée le caniveau de
l'humanité la téléréalité jerry pas si
si si si si mais moi mais moi même mais
moi je je je pourrais même faire une
parenthèse
j'accepterai une dictature c'était juste
pour supprimer ces émissions là juste
pour ça mais moi sabrage haut-rhin
dictature qui n'interviendrait que pour
ça et qui dit sans l'éliminer moi ça
fait juste service et vous voyez bien
quand même oui mais c'est pire mais ces
pilleurs je m'en fou balle et je parlais
sur la preuve avec mes talons
je sais pas moi même à saint tropez mais
moche pas bien dans les pays chauds des
gens ils vont en talons à la plage moi
j'ai toujours nu on sait jamais il ya un
an pékin qui passe devant moi sur la
plage au mexique ben voilà nous sommes
même pas lui
[Musique]
sourire et nous atterrir et nouent des
liens des fastes du palais et de l'image
d'une reine couronnée s'est entouré de
ses poney blanc que la reine elizabeth a
voulu se montrer debout dans une cave
vers sabha insolite portrait d'une
nonagénaire qui n'a finalement pas
beaucoup changé un clin d'oeil fidèles
de celle qui préfère la simplicité
regardez la reine d'angleterre en barbie
pour fêter les soixante dix ans de son
règne ne sais pas si c'est très
ressemblants mais en tout cas le portois
moi c'était aujourd'hui à la 96 ans
lewis est aujourd'hui 96 aux blessures
pour les 70 ans de son règne c'est pas
la première fois que mattel fait ça
voilà avec une tiare inspirée de celle
qu'elle portait à son mariage avec un
air très décidée s'est vendu qu'à
londres cette dernière apparition sur le
grand écran il l'a fait dans goliath
sorti au mois de mars
vous vous battiez un dernier rôle en
forme d'adieu jacques perrin est décédé
à l'âge de 80 ans